so now I will go to the
very high level understanding of the
health informatics data types
so there are multiple types of data and
actually you can imagine every sort of
biomedical data biotech data Healthcare
data
free clinical notes
social network posts Facebook posts
Twitter post everything can be used in
the context of healthcare informatics
even the
advisory your dietary intake the the
dietary level of the
a cheap switch you take or any fast food
so everything everything and anything is
actually can be used to build
very important use cases for health
informatics
but I will cover the most frequent and
mostly used things so the first of it is
emrs so what are emrs emrs are actually
electronic medical records so it's like
in majority of the countries we that
they have implemented the EMR so instead
of capturing all the clinical nodes we
have the digitized format so those emrs
are actually a Content structured and
semi-structured data and these EMR is a
very rich source of healthcare data
next is medical images so images can be
x-ray CT scan MRI so these are mainly
static images we can also have video
images of suppose fetal scan and Fetal
anomalies can endoscopy bronchoscopy
so all sort of image and videos this
fall under the domain of medical images
and these for for medical image analysis
we do need a very specific set of skills
and specific set of
algorithms which mainly fall under the
domain of computer vision so computer
vision is what drives Medical Imaging
and medical image classification
next is histopathology so actually our
body is consists of organs tissues and
cells so microscopic tissue tissue
sections are is what we call as his
histology so and uh microscopic
appearance of a particular tissue in
case of a disease versus in case of a
healthy person is different so
identifying those microscopic
differences by using machine learning
techniques is what falls under the
pathological Health informatics
lastly all all students who come from
the biotech domain we know multi-ohmics
data so multiomics contains genomics
transcriptomics proteomics and
metabolomics there are also other omics
data so and this High throughput data of
genomics and mass mass spectrometry
these are also used for
Health informatics cases so nowadays
people are talking about Precision
therapy in cancer in cancer you profile
the particular tissue you profile the
particular
genomic
structure of the tissue you you profile
it using single cell transcriptomics you
find out the main genes which are
perturbed for that for that patient and
you give them a very precise drug as per
that particular Gene profile
next is epidemiological data so
epidemiology actually consists of
population level data so socioeconomic
background education public health
conditions what is the literacy what is
the socioeconomic status how many cars
do I own what is my lifestyle
and these All Things fall under the
category of economical data and actually
from this data we can find out very very
useful insights of multiple diseases so
we can so suppose in the context of
kovit we can find out that which are the
main geographical Pockets from which
kovit is more
concentrated
in the in the context of any lifestyle
disease we can tell that in which
particular population whether it male or
female or males from which particular
part of the country they are more prone
to develop diabetes
and other diseases so this helps us to
detect population level insights so that
we can change the public health policy
accordingly and there also views
informatics
then I already mentioned about time
series data these are mainly data live
streaming data coming from fitbits and
variables like Apple watch or a Samsung
watch like that and from that we can
predict time series analysis and we can
predict a particular event which is
going to come so in the context of
giatric population there is one
important use case called fall
prediction so basically geriatric people
tend to fall very often because of the
lack of proper Mistresses in the blood
pressure so as for the blood pressure
suddenly drops down so if we can predict
from the
past records of blood pressure that this
person is going to have the blood
pressure gradually dropping down and
these and hence an impending fall so we
can
maybe even alert or a notification with
the particular person and the concerned
healthcare workers or the relatives to
tell that this person is going to have a
particular fall and actually fall
incidents do cause a huge burden on the
Healthcare System
in the west as well as in the east
so it's a very important use case fault
for the healthcare organizations
so clinical notes so actually emrs are
not yet
implemented in majority of the countries
we till we still have clinical notes and
these clinical notes are actually they
they are there in sort of silos they are
isolated they are not usable for the
informatics or inside generation so we
have to convert the clinical nodes to a
digital format now this conversion of
clinical nodes to digital format we use
something called OCR now after OCR we
use something called natural language
process called NLP this OCR NLP helps us
to extract clinical note into digital
format and then provide insights and
lastly social network data so you can do
sentiment analysis from Twitter posts
that this person is having this
sentiment as detected by their multiple
posts over the last six months so that
can cause so that tells me that this
person is a high risk for a depression
and maybe a suicide so these suicide
detection and all the mental health
problems this we can do from the
ah these sort of data
so again so this variety of data and
combining all sorts of data
into the by data specific format for a
particular prediction or inside
generation this is what health
informatics consists of and we will be
going to have a very good understanding
of this particular thing in the course
and we will be going to discuss two to
three case studies in this course and
also with the Hands-On session